pour l'instant mon tarek ton film
s'appelle 30 jours max et comme dit un
homme de défis je vais proposer des
défis semble que tu auras 30 secondes
max pour réaliser 30 dur max il faut
aller le voir mercredi je vous dis c'est
exceptionnel tu as 30 secondes max pour
me dire parmi les chroniqueurs à qui tu
donnerais le premier rôle dans son
prochain film
je dirais à benjamin cragin super alors
je peux moi on passera jamais il est
venu me voir tout à l'heure dans les
loges et il a fait que des beaux
compliments sur sur mon fils mais voilà
j'ai trouvé ça très sympathique de sa
part d'un rire me voir pour démonter la
règle est bâti non mais il aime le
cinéma
tu remarqueras que le il parle très très
bien des films quand il les a pas vus
c'est une [ __ ]
il ay la dia toute l'équipe délai absolu
bon voilà on ya tous été ça va mal et à
30 secondes max pour transformer savais
que j'allais te le demande et comptines
hasard en cinq animaux différents les
animaux j'ai eu des problèmes que la
espère le droit j'ai pas le droit de
faire ça il en mesure c'est vrai ah
ouais non mais sa demi tour
[Applaudissements]
moi au moins un hommage au liban comme
youtube ou en bon ça me procure un peu
comme pour moi je te jure après je te
jure je te demande plus rien miami mais
plus jamais ayalon qu'il fait bon ménage
chez nous aussi ce type au camp après on
te le demande plus choc si longtemps
j'ai pas fait du coup tout cas je vois
que tu chantes tu perds pas la mort à
trente secondes pour éviter des
chanteuses de r'n'b je sais que tu fais
à la perfection il y en a qu à moi et il
menace aussi tu là les mutuelles il ya
une musique ou pas venir me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
taratata
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon
je peux pas le joueur s'est vu sans quoi
cette vidéo aller en mer
[Musique]
sais tu
[Applaudissements]
dernier truc à 30 secondes max pour
appeler une ancienne miss france et
obtenir un rencard faut le faire
maintenant alors si tu veux on a des nos
moeurs si tu veux on a le numéro de
malika ménard kenny qui est très belle
mais toi tu veux ou pas mais le gérant
de dire non donc c'est obligatoire elle
est obligatoire
j'ai ressenti des français on l'appelle
henry malika ménard ah non on est pas en
couple alors à l'eau alors malika oui
ouais c'est avec boudali ça va ça va je
te dérange mais qu'est ce que j'ai vu
c'était juste parce qu'en fait si je
vais faire mon avant-première et du coup
je voulais savoir si tu voulais venir
mais en fait je préfère être honnête
avec toi ton nom qui circule dans les
murs et effectuer les dragons que ok
bonne soirée mais tu te rends pas
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce qu'elle méritait je sais
pas mais en plus il a donc séduit
battant faire ce pas possible mais que
lanaudière
[Applaudissements]
resterait toujours le cas malika ménard
est avec brio